Donald Trump is now proposing a
state-run media network to show the
world how great he is and how great his
administration is one of the hallmarks
of authoritarian autocratic regimes is
state-run propaganda media networks
where the reports about what government
are doing are coming from government
funded media outlets so what I'm talking
about here is how Russia has RT how the
Qatari government funds al Jazeera how
Venezuela funds this channel called
talas or which you may or may not have
heard of how North Korea has that state
media station
I think it's KCNA I think it's called
China has it there are many many
examples of this and Trump has been
trying to figure out how to get that
pesky media to stop reporting the truth
about him and his administration and
he's floated I mean let's think back Pat
he had the idea of journalism licenses
very early on in his campaign he wanted
to open up libel laws to make it easier
to sue media outlets he's threatened to
shut down media that he doesn't like
with an executive order doesn't appear
as though that would be legal I'm
forgetting some others I feel like but
remember there is no bigger fan of free
speech and a free press than Donald
Trump and so now in that spirit of free
free free speech and a free press Donald
Trump is floating the idea of state-run
media he tweeted about this yesterday
saying quote while CNN doesn't do great
in the United States based on ratings
outside of the US they have very little
competition throughout the world CNN has
a powerful voice portraying the United
States in an unfair and false way
something has to be done including the
possibility of the United States
starting our own worldwide network to
show the world the way we really are
great that's right the president is
suggesting a pro Trump
state-run Channel
to show the rest of the world how great
everything is in the United States and
how great everything is that is done by
the United States it's effectively a
Ministry of propaganda okay someone
wrote to me saying David we have this
already
it's called Fox News to which I said
well yeah we basically do have it
although Fox News sometimes lets the
truth slip out when chef Smith is on the
air or sometimes when Chris Wallace is
on the air one time when Neil Cavuto was
on the air the truth slipped out a trump
state media would not allow that it
would just be all Trump all the time and
interestingly this is just so funny cuz
Trump clearly has no idea about this the
u.s. actually does sort of have this
already there is a network called Voice
of America which broadcast around the
world and it's basically PR for the u.s.
in foreign countries Trump may be
totally unaware of it but even voice of
America's director Amanda Bennett said
last year she's not going to be
manipulated by Trump so it may be a sort
of pro-us
worldwide network but it's not going to
be Trump's personal propaganda tool so
clearly Trump wants something here
that's more like RT in Russia or KCNA in
North Korea or Telus or in Venezuela
he's proposing things that normally the
right says we have to be careful with
like what happened Pat to the right
saying it's dangerous when the
government controls the media but now
Trump says it or Trump does it when it
comes to other policies and all of a
sudden the right says either oh he's
just kidding around or it's no longer
something we have to worry about it's
not a double standard because of course
it's just okay when Trump does it but do
you remember in the early days of the
Trump administration lera Trump launched
the real news update it was like two or
three minute long Facebook videos that's
apparently still going on so maybe we
can scale that up that can be the new
propaganda arm that Trump is searching
for it's clearly what he wants and this
is what happens in authoritarian regimes
and the truth is that if anything we
have the opposite problem like yeah you
do see some critical reporting about
Trump
but given what Trump is doing there's
should be way more of that serious
critical reporting about disaster that
is the Trump administration and then I
was reminded imagine of a station that
simply broadcasts every Trump speech
without comment worldwide every press
conference that he gives every executive
order signing ceremony but not with
commentary that would do more to turn
the world against Donald Trump than you
can imagine and it's just a sign of the
hyper normalization that we are
experiencing a call by the President of
the United States for state-run media
and it's like on the third or fourth
page of the top news stories of the day
online because of the hyper
normalization that we've experienced
something this nuts
imagine if Obama did this imagine if
Bush did this it barely gets attention
when it's happening in the Trump era
follow the David Pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show follow me
at David Pakman a lotta
behind-the-scenes pictures comments
highlighted comments from the audience
and much more quick break
Andrew Torres will join me next to talk
about court packing what is it can
Democrats do it should Democrats do it
one of the day's sponsors is privacy
calm slash Pakman which is a free
service that I myself use really useful
in many different ways takes just a few
seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a David Pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy com icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link